Gunshots echo down the concrete hallway of
Site-22.
Screams are the only thing that escape each
room.
A team of men in all black combat gear and
masks move from one section of the complex
to the next.
Pietro Wilson hides in his office, listening
to the cries for mercy of his colleagues.
He shakes uncontrollably with fear.
Who are they? he thinks.
Why are they killing everyone and how did
they find us?
Moments earlier Pietro Wilson had been in
the canteen eating dinner with other staff
members.
A group of heavily armed men entered the room.
They stood silently surveying the area.
One of the scientists stood up and asked if
they could assist them.
That’s when the carnage started.
One of the masked men raised his rifle and
shot the scientists in the head.
Chaos broke out as the other mercenaries raised
their weapons and began firing.
Bullets flew everywhere and Pietro was lucky
not to be struck or trampled as he escaped
out the back door of the cafeteria.
He ran to his office, slammed the door shut,
and hid under his desk.
Now he sits on the floor with his legs pulled
up to his chest shaking uncontrollably.
After a couple of minutes he manages to take
a deep breath and slows his heart rate.
He regains control of his body, but is still
filled with fear and adrenaline.
Pietro crawls on his belly to his office door.
He reaches up and pulls down on the handle.
There is a slight click as the latch releases.
He opens the door just a crack and peers out
into the hallway.
The flickering emergency lights illuminate
the corridor for a few seconds at a time before
plunging it back into darkness.
There is no one in sight, but from around
the corner flashes of light from machine gun
fire flickers down the hall.
The screams of the workers at Site-22 are
silenced.
Pietro takes a deep breath and pushes the
door open further.
He crawls out of his office and starts moving
away from the violence.
Unfortunately, to get away from the mayhem
he must go deeper into the bowels of Site-22.
The exit is the other way, but he is too scared
to head towards the armed men.
He stands up and brushes the dirt from his
blue technician jumpsuit.
The lights flicker off, the hallway goes dark.
He reaches out his hands and comes into contact
with the cool damp wall.
He feels his way down the corridor, swimming
in darkness.
After a few moments the lights flicker back
on.
Pietro looks over his shoulder to make sure
he is still in the clear.
Standing at the end of the hall is a soldier
dressed in all black with a mask covering
his face.
The soldier stands motionless.
Pietro turns to face the soldier, his eyes
open wide, his heart races, he can’t breath.
The figure doesn’t move.
Then the lights flicker out again and Pietro
pushes off the wall and runs, blind in the
darkness.
He sprints as fast as he can when suddenly
there is a loud crack and a bullet whizzes
by his head.
He can feel the wind as it barely misses his
cheek.
He continues to run.
The lights flicker back on, he peers over
his shoulder.
Now there is an entire group of armed men
pursuing him down the hallway, guns raised.
He turns the corner of the hallway and proceeds
down a set of stairs further into Site-22.
At the bottom of the stairway there is a short
corridor with a door at the end of it.
There’s nowhere else to go.
He pulls a key card out of his pocket and
fumbles it.
The card falls to the ground.
Pietro bends down to pick it up and as he
leans over a bullet whizzes past where his
head had just been.
The projectile embeds itself into the metal
door.
He scoops his key card up off the ground and
shoves it against the scanner.
The door unlocks and he dashes into the room.
He quickly turns and shuts the door.
It locks automatically.
The last thing he sees is the assassins running
towards the door.
The lights flicker on in the room where Pietro
stands.
The room has only one door, no windows, and
no vents.
It is completely isolated.
In the middle of the room is SCP-5000.
He knew there was a SCP in this room that
was designated SCP-5000, but he never knew
what it actually was.
Here he is now, staring at it.
A strange looking mechanical harness hanging
in the middle of the room.
Suddenly, loud banging at the door fills the
room.
The armed men are trying to break in.
It is only a matter of time before they pry
the door open.
With nowhere to go Pietro Wilson knows that
he is dead.
He looks at SCP-5000 and shakes his head.
“What do I have to lose?” he says out
loud.
Only your life, a voice inside his head responds.
He walks over to SCP-5000 and pulls it down
from where it's hanging.
It is heavy.
On the mechanical suit are symbols he does
not recognize.
The only things he knows about the suit are
rumors he’s heard from others who work at
Site-22.
Supposedly, it first appeared in a flash of
light in the containment chamber of a Keter
level SCP at Site-62C.
The designation of this Keter was SCP-579.
The only other thing that Pietro knows is
that everyone at Site-62C was slaughtered
when containment was breached.
SCP-5000 was found deactivated next to a pile
of bodies.
He slips on the harness and Ss if it has a
life of its own, SCP-5000 begins to adjust
itself to the exact dimensions of his body.
The suit grows and snakes across his skin,
wrapping every appendage in armor.
Then it begins to tighten.
Pietro Wilson starts to scream as SCP-5000
envelops him.
The suit rises up the back of his neck and
encases his entire head, silencing his screams.
The door to the room blasts open from a controlled
explosion.
As the dust and smoke settles the masked men
enter the room.
Their flashlights move from side to side as
they search for the elusive technician who
had just entered.
There is no one in the room.
All that is there is an empty rack in the
middle of the chamber.
The men fan out, but there is no other exit.
The room is just a solid square of concrete.
They are baffled.
“Where did he go?” one of them shouts.
Pietro Wilson had blacked out from the pain
of the suit attaching to his body.
He comes to still standing in the middle of
the room.
All around him are men in black combat gear.
They are searching for him.
He holds his breath and closes his eyes.
But the gun shots never come.
He opens one of his eyes and looks around.
Why haven’t they killed me yet? he thinks.
He slowly turns his head as men walk by him
with their guns raised.
He hears someone say, “where did he go?”
I’m right here, he thinks.
Am I dead?
Pietro looks down to see that his entire body
is contained within SCP-5000.
He lifts his hand and waves it in front of
his face.
He is still clearly alive, but it seems as
if the killers can’t see him.
He walks up to one of the mercenaries and
waves his hand in front of the man’s face.
There is no reaction.
The suit made me invisible, he thinks.
Pietro looks at one of the men to see if he
can find out who they are and why they have
killed everyone at the base.
On the sleeve of the man’s jacket are the
words Zeta-19.
He’s never heard of Zeta-19 before, but
they must be a part of an organization that
is trying to undermine the SCP Foundation.
The men continue to search the empty room,
clearly confused as to where the technician
went.
Pietro weaves his way through the group of
men and back out the door he had entered from.
On his way through the wreckage that used
to be a door, Pietro Wilson trips on some
debris.
He reaches out to steady himself, but he is
falling.
He closes his eyes knowing that as soon as
he hits the ground all of the men hunting
him will be alerted by the sound of his fall.
But the impact never comes.
When Pietro opens his eyes it is as if he
is hovering just above the ground.
He looks down at his feet.
The toes of the suit are firmly planted on
the floor like powerful magnets on iron.
SCP-5000 has prevented his fall and is holding
him in place using the feet of the suit only.
He reaches out his hand and gently places
it on the ground.
He pushes himself up to a standing position.
He turns to look back into the room, the men
are still in there searching for him.
Pietro makes his way back through Site-22.
He walks by his office and proceeds towards
the exit of the facility.
As he passes the labs and other rooms at Site-22
all he finds is carnage.
Everyone has been killed.
An extra bullet has been placed in each person’s
head to make sure.
It seems that the only mission these men were
on was to kill everyone, and make sure they
stayed dead.
He continues towards the exit of Site-22 that
is guarded by two men.
As he approaches the two heavily armed men,
Pietro makes sure to be as quiet as possible.
This is not a difficult task as the SCP-5000
has given him stealth capabilities.
He notices that even his footsteps aren’t
giving off any sound.
It is almost as if the suit is allowing him
to glide across the floor.
He is almost to the exit, then he will be
home free.
He takes a deep breath, turns sideways, and
squeezes past the two men guarding the doorway.
Just as he is about to leave this nightmare
behind, one of the guards turns unexpectedly.
The man’s shoulder runs directly into Pietro
Wilson throwing him off balance.
He is knocked into the second guard, both
of the men begin to scream.
“What is that?” one of them shouts.
They begin to raise their guns on the invisible
object that just bumped into them.
It’s then that SCP-5000 takes over Pietro’s
body.
The suit raises his arm and grabs one of the
men by the throat.
With a squeeze the man’s larynx is instantly
crushed.
Then the suit twists slightly and snaps the
man’s neck.
It turns to face the second man.
Even the black mask the man is weaning can’t
hide the look of terror on his face, but Pietro
has no control over what SCP-5000 is doing.
He has never killed before.
The suit launches Pietro’s body into the
second man, pinning him against the wall.
It then grabs the top of the mercenary’s
head and slams it against the concrete again,
and again, and again, until the man’s screams
are silenced.
The suit lets go of the man and his lifeless
body slides to the ground as Pietro blacks
out.
When he regains consciousness, he’s outside
of Site-22 standing on top of a hill, looking
down at the facility below.
He looks at his hands, then at the rest of
his body.
He is still contained within SCP-5000.
There is a flash of light and a heads up display
comes on.
He doesn’t recognize any of the symbols,
but as his eyes move from one area of the
screen to the next, the symbols become highlighted.
Before his eyes certain symbols begin to translate
into words he can read.
One of the symbols now says: Journal Entry.
Unsure of what else to do, Pietro begins recounting
what happened to him at Site-22.
He makes his way through the desert towards
the nearest SCP Foundation safe house.
He knows once there he will be able to reach
out to his superiors for help and further
orders.
Maybe he can even find a way to get SCP-5000
to release him.
As he trudges along, Pietro Wilson notices
that his brain is telling him he is thirsty.
But the vitals on the suit’s heads up display
say he is in good health.
In fact, he is better than good, his vitals
are all perfect.
The suit seems to be giving him all the nutrients
his body needs.
It has even fixed his busted knee that was
injured back in college playing football.
The joint itself has somehow been healed.
Pietro finally reaches the safe house and
opens the door.
It is quiet and dusty.
It looks as if no one has been there in years.
He walks over to the communications station
and tries to contact the Foundation but all
he gets is static.
He gives up and walks over to the TV.
He pushes the on button, the screen hisses
to life.
What he sees causes his jaw to drop.
SCPs had been let loose around the world and
were killing people by the millions.
What was going on?
Pietro was startled awake from a nightmare.
He was hyperventilating, but his body almost
immediately recovered, and his breathing slowed.
A heads up display flashed on infront of his
eyes.
Pietro Wilson was still contained within SCP-5000.
The suit would not let him go.
He instinctively went to rub his eyes, but
the metal hands of the suit just clanked against
the helmet that covered his head.
He wanted out of this suit!
Pietro stood up and walked over to the television.
He reached out to turn it on but paused.
He thought: Do I really want to see how bad
things have gotten since I fell asleep?
But he had to know.
He was filled with dread as the TV came on
and he saw the first images.
The world looked as if it was ending, and
it seemed like the SCP Foundation was responsible.
How could this be?
They were supposed to protect humanity not
destroy it.
Pietro needed to uncover the truth behind
what was happening.
SCP-5000 had a log entry function that he
could use to record everything he uncovered.
Even if he didn’t make it out of this alive,
maybe one day someone would find the suit
and be able to access what he had learned.
The date of his first journal entry was February
1, 2020.
As Pietro watched the carnage unfold on TV,
he began to put together the pieces of what
he had witnessed himself.
He knew a special-ops squad had executed everyone
at Site-22 where he worked.
He knew that the SCPs had been let loose.
He knew the world was ending… but why?
As Pietro pondered this, a newscaster appeared.
“What you have just witnessed are reports
from around the world of monsters ravaging
cities and towns.
This all started with a mysterious message
from an organization that calls itself the
SCP Foundation.
Their ruling body, named the O5 Council, released
the following statement: ‘For those who
are not currently aware of our existence,
we represent the organization known as the
SCP Foundation.
Our previous mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects, entities,
and other assorted phenomena.
This mission was the focus of our organization
for more than one-hundred years.
Due to circumstances outside of our control,
this directive has now changed.
Our new mission will be the extermination
of the human race.
There will be no further communication.”
He couldn’t believe what he was seeing.
The SCP Foundation had declared war on the
human race.
How could this be?
What had led to the O5 council changing their
entire mission from protecting humanity to
ending it?
Could it be possible that a powerful SCP had
taken control or influenced the council’s
decision?
Pietro turned on the radio, flipped through
TV channels, and scoured the internet for
information on what had happened over the
past 24 hours.
The first image he saw was a human-like creature
with arms and legs twice as long as they should
have been, with deep black eyes, and a mouth
curled up into a silent scream showing teeth
as sharp as razor blades.
From the files he could access Pietro learned
that this was SCP-096, a creature that was
docile until someone saw its face, at which
point the SCP would start to shriek and cry,
before hunting down whoever saw its face and
slaughtering them.
He quickly changed the channel.
The file said that even if SCP-096 was seen
on a screen, it would find the viewer and
tear them limb from limb.
Surely that couldn’t be true.
There were potentially millions of people
who had just seen it on TV.
What would happen to them?
What would happen to him?
On the next channel was footage of a gigantic
animal in the middle of the ocean.
This was SCP-169, a leviathan from the Pre-Cambrian
era.
The creature was around 5,000 kilometers long
and slowly swam just below the surface of
the ocean.
The feed suddenly changed to footage of devastating
tsunamis and destruction caused by earthquakes.
When SCP-169 had been awoken from its slumber
by the Foundation detonating nukes on its
back, it began trying to escape the danger.
The movement of the massive creature caused
natural disasters, destroying coastal communities
around the world.
On another channel Pietro watched as the chancellor
of Germany gave a speech, announcing that
the country was declaring war on the SCP Foundation.
Off camera the sound of a tinkling bell could
be heard.
A man dressed as a Victorian era butler entered
and picked up a pen from the Chancellor's
desk.
He approached the Chancellor and raised the
pen in the air as the camera cut away, but
the sound of gunshots and yelling could be
heard before the feed went dead.
The news reported that similar events involving
world leaders by the exact same butler had
been occurring since the SCP Foundation changed
its mission.
Pietro searched through the suit’s files
to try and figure out what was happening and
found that SCP-662 must have been connected.
Next was a strange skin disease plaguing New
York and Delhi designated SCP-610 that covered
its host in rashes and boils before seeking
to take over their bodies.
Finally some good news though, as the outbreak
looked to be contained by the combined efforts
of the Global Occult Coalition and the Church
of the Broken God.
And then some bad news, as SCP-682 had also
been released.
A massive crocodilian monster, it’s sole
mission was to destroy all life.
It was fueled by hatred for living things,
making it the perfect tool of the O5 Council’s
new stated mission.
Pietro had heard rumors of SCPs that could
instantly end the world, but clearly the Foundation
hadn’t gone down this route… yet.
Did they want to keep the rest of the planet
intact, or maybe there were hold outs in the
SCP Foundation who were trying to stop the
O5 Council from carrying out their mission?
All Pietro knew was that right now, there
were some real nasty SCPs running around wreaking
havoc.
Pietro suddenly heard an explosion in the
distance.
Far away, but still close enough to make him
nervous.
Maybe he was better off staying in the safehouse
and waiting out the apocalypse.
The suit was keeping him healthy, nourished,
and undetectable to foes.
Any sane person would have remained there
in seclusion and safety, but Pietro needed
answers.
He felt it was his responsibility to log and
try to make sense of everything the SCP Foundation
was doing.
He brought up a map of SCP sites in the area
on his display.
The closest was Site-19.
It was time to venture out into the end of
the world and find some answers.
But he was about to be faced with even more
questions.
On the way to Site-19, Pietro came across
something strange - a squad of Foundation
soldiers in a clearing.
They were standing at attention as their commander
paced back and forth, up and down the line.
The soldiers' uniforms had the insignia “MTF
Epsilon-6” embroidered on them.
The commander stopped in front of the first
soldier in the line, clapped her hands, and
informed the soldier she would be beginning
the check now.
The commander pulled out a long knife and
plunged it into the soldier’s shoulder.
Strangely, the soldier did not move, make
a sound, or react in any way.
She moved to the next soldier and repeated
the same process.
This continued down the line until she reached
the eighth soldier.
This time when the commander stabbed the shoulder
of the soldier, he noticeably winced and cried
out in pain.
The commander shouted “got a live one!”
Pietro watched as the soldiers raised their
guns and fired at the one who had cried out.
He dropped to the ground.
The commander moved on to the last soldier
and put the knife in his shoulder.
There was no reaction.
“Alright we’re clear,” yelled the commander.
“Let’s move out!”
Pietro waited until the squad was out of sight
and made his way to the corpse lying on the
ground.
He scavenged weapons and basic medical supplies,
then he buried the body and recorded what
he had seen in SCP-5000’s log.
He had no idea why this soldier was killed,
or why the others didn’t feel pain.
Maybe they weren’t human at all?
Maybe it was a squad of SCPs that had a human
infiltrate their ranks?
None of this makes sense, Piertro thought,
before continuing on.
Upon reaching Site-19, Pietro found it in
disarray, and worse, practically all of the
SCPs that were held at the site had breached
containment.
He was able to walk into the compound unnoticed
and deep in the facility he found scientists
and researchers going about their business
as if they had no idea what was happening
out in the world.
They must have been following the orders of
the O5 Council.
Pietro listened in on conversations about
how to create the maximum number of human
casualties, and which SCP should be released
next.
He felt a deep hatred for the people in this
facility.
How could they be so casual about wiping out
humanity?
As he observed more of the workers at Site-19,
he noticed something strange.
Everyones’ eyes were cold and dead, like
there was no humanity left in them, as if
something had gotten to these scientists and
removed the very souls from their bodies.
Pietro stealthily stole a senior staff member’s
credentials and found an empty office where
he could access logs from the facility, to
try and get a better idea of the timeline
of events that led to the SCP Foundation’s
war on humanity.
He logged into the mainframe and brought up
entries from the end of the previous year.
He found that late in 2019 a project called
‘PNEUMA’ became of great interest to the
O5 council.
From what Pietro could tell, the project had
something to do with the collective human
consciousness, also called the psychospace.
Apparently, SCP researchers had a breakthrough
in mapping out the psychospace.
Unfortunately, many of the files had been
redacted, and there was no way for Pietro
to access the unredacted version.
After ‘PNEUMA’ had been brought to the
attention of the O5 Council, a series of orders
were sent to all senior staff and site directors
but frustratingly these orders had also been
redacted.
All he could see was that after the orders
were sent out, a wave of resignations were
submitted across the Foundation.
Suspiciously, a wave of suicides had also
occurred at roughly the same time.
What was in these orders?!
The 05 council then sent out a number of files
to all senior staff and site directors with
instructions to disseminate the materials
among those serving under them, after which
both the resignations and deaths immediately
ceased.
Pietro searched everywhere for what was in
those files, but like so much of the SCP database,
this information had been redacted as well.
What was clear was that the SCP Foundation
had begun gearing up for the extermination
of humanity the following year.
The entry log for February 1, 2020 read: “Mobile
Task Forces are dispatched to all Exclusionary
Sites to execute all personnel.
Immediately following the conclusion of these
missions, the Foundation declares war on humanity.”
This was where Pietro Wilson’s journey had
started.
He slammed his hands down on the computer
monitor in frustration.
The suit absorbed all of the impact and crushed
the monitor in half.
Pietro moved to a new, non smashed computer,
and logged in again.
This time he brought up the most current entries
to see what the O5 Council was up to recently
to see if there were some answers in the present.
The SCP Foundation had been busy while he
was making his way to Site-19.
They had released SCP-1048 in Paris, which
now led a horde of bears down the Champs Elysées.
In the distance Pietro thought he could almost
make out a massive red teddy bear walking
between the buildings.
The SCP Foundation was also launching counterattacks
on any organization that tried to oppose them.
They used SCP-1290 to hurl projectiles at
the Global Occult Coalition’s base.
They were also using SCP-1440 to brainwash
people and convince them that they needed
to riot.
This caused widespread destruction as people
panicked and were trampled to death.
Pietro thought it was sad that such a kind
looking old man could cause so much destruction.
He recorded as much as he could before deciding
that it was time to get out of Site-19.
Although SCP-5000 still made him undetectable,
he couldn’t shake the feeling that the lifeless
eyes of the staff were beginning to look his
way more and more often.
As Pietro exited Site-19, the sky glowed orange
with the fire of countless burning buildings.
He needed to find more answers.
He needed to uncover the reason the SCP Foundation
was trying to wipe out humanity.
He had learned a lot from Site-19, and was
sure that if he could just get to the next
site, he would finally be able to figure out
the Foundation’s motive, and maybe even
how to stop them.
He took a step forward but his heads up display
suddenly went completely dark.
The suit constricted tighter around his body,
slowing the blood flow to his brain.
He couldn’t move as his vision got dimmer,
and dimmer, and dimmer, until he blacked out.
“What happened?”
Pietro says out loud as he looks at his vitals
in the heads up display of SCP-5000.
He is still contained within the exclusionary
suit that makes him undetectable to human
senses.
He checks the date and gasps in surprise.
“Three months!
I’ve been passed out for three months!”
He stands up and looks across the barren landscape.
The screen inside the suit indicates he has
traversed half of the country since he left
Site-19 three months ago.
Pietro looks down at one of his hands.
He is holding a black leather briefcase.
“Where did that come from?” he wonders.
Pietro has no idea what is inside the briefcase,
but he knows it definitely isn’t round.
He tries to let it go, his fingers won’t
open.
He uses his other hand to try and pry the
briefcase away from himself, but his hand
only clasps to it harder.
Then a wave of calm washes over him.
Something inside his head speaks to him, but
it’s not a voice, more like a feeling.
It is a sense of purpose, and Pietro’s new
mission in life is to deliver this briefcase
to SCP-579, nothing else is as important.
Pietro Wilson takes a deep breath and embraces
his new purpose in life.
He still wants to uncover the reason that
the SCP Foundation is trying to wipe out humanity,
but this will have to wait until he delivers
the briefcase to SCP-579.
Pietro does not know exactly where 579 is
located, but he can feel a pull in a certain
direction, so he begins to walk.
Pietro brings up the information stored in
the SCP-5000 suit from the Foundation’s
database.
He finds that all information about what SCP-579
is has been expunged from the record.
The only useful information in the file is
that the Keter level SCP is located at Site-62c.
At least Pietro has a destination to aim for.
He travels for days without seeing a living
soul.
But he does pass thousands of corpses.
He tries to ignore them but one stands out
to him inside a house as he searches for supplies.
It's the body of a recently deceased boy.
He couldn't have been more than eight years
old.
He was so young, Pietro thinks.
He bends over to scoop up the body and bury
it outside.
As his hand touches the body, the boy’s
skin begins to move.
It is as if hundreds of tiny creatures are
scurrying just under the skin.
Then, from out of every orifice, comes hundreds
of little pale worms.
each with the face of the boy.
They are all cackling as they crawl off the
boy’s body and into a drain a few feet away.
Pietro jumps back and runs.
That is the last person I try to bury, he
thinks.
Pietro pushes forward, the hundreds of little
laughing worms haunting his thoughts, until
he puts a significant distance between himself
and the little boy’s body.
Pietro continues to walk towards the direction
of Site-62c.
He passes more corpses, but decides to stay
clear of them.
Although the suit makes it so Pietro doesn’t
need to rest, he can only go so fast.
He enters a small abandoned town that looks
like something out of an old western movie.
A tumbleweed blows across the dirt road.
Pietro sits on the wooden step of the local
saloon and takes a break.
He looks down at the briefcase in his hand.
He hasn’t had the urge to open it, only
to deliver it to SCP-579.
Pietro puts the black briefcase on his lap.
He stares at it and slides his hands along
the leather, stops with his thumb on the latch,
and pushes.
The silver locks snap open.
Pietro opens the briefcase... a bright light
beams out, and he passes out.
When Pietro comes to again he is miles closer
to Site-62c.
There is a warm feeling enveloping his body.
He looks down at the briefcase which is now
closed.
Wow, this thing is like my own personal skip
button, Pietro thinks.
He holds up the briefcase, unlatches the locks,
sees the bright light, and passes out again.
He awakes once again miles away from his last
position.
So it wasn’t just a one-off effect.
Pietro continues walking across the country,
switching between using his own legs and whatever
magic is contained within the briefcase.
He is making faster progress now.
As he walks through a dense deciduous forest
he comes across a pack of wolves eating the
remains of an SCP Agent.
Pietro is undetectable to the wolves thanks
to the SCP-5000 suit and he makes his way
over to the pack, quietly grabbing a laptop
laying on the ground next to the agent’s
body.
Pietro takes the laptop and goes a way deeper
into the forest before stopping to boot up
the computer.
He has not forgotten about the horrors the
SCP Foundation has released and he needs to
know how the world has been doing over the
last few months.
What he finds is... not good.
The SCP Foundation has triggered the eruption
of Yellowstone destroying SCP-2000, which
unknown to Pietro, contained the failsafe
for rebuilding human society in the event
of a world ending scenario, which this was
starting to look more and more like.
It was only a matter of time now before the
soot and ash thrown up by the eruption blocks
out the sun in much of what is left of the
United States.
The Foundation has also found a way to get
SCP-2241 to do their dirty work at refugee
camps.
The young brown haired boy is most likely
being manipulated by the Foundation under
the pretenses that they are only doing what’s
best for “their” child.
He has caused whole groups of refugees to
turn on eachother, leading to a massacre.
The last entry says that the young boy is
being sent to the The Global Occult Coalition
hold out at Ganzir, to help destroy some of
the last threats to the SCP Foundation.
A series of other SCPs have been dispatched
by the Foundation around the world to continue
the destruction of humanity.
They even managed to use temporal anomalies
to make it Christmas time everywhere around
the world so SCP-4666, the brutal Yule-tide
creature that stalks the homes of children,
is free to cause chaos.
Pietro had seen enough.
He slams the laptop shut, throws it against
the trunk of a tree., and opens the briefcase
again.
He awakes standing feet away from a group
of Global Occult Coalition soldiers who are
sitting around a campfire.
Maybe they know why the SCP Foundation is
trying to end the world, he thinks.
He decides that it is too risky to show himself
to the soldiers, but takes some solace in
sitting around the campfire with other living
humans.
The soldiers are sharing stories about what
is happening, one catches the attention of
Pietro Wilson.
It is strange, but also may hold a clue as
to why the SCP Foundation is trying to wipe
out humanity.
One of the soldiers recounts an event that
he witnessed before leaving the Global Occult
Coalition’s headquarters at Ganzir.
They had just captured an SCP soldier trying
to break into the base.
The infiltrator's name was Samuel Ross.
He had been strapped into an interrogation
chair and questioned.
The interviewers were not getting anywhere
until Ross was threatened with torture, to
which he responded “Do what you want.
Once you realize you're not supposed to feel
pain, there's nothing to be afraid of anymore.”
Pietro sits up straight and starts to listen
more intently.
He remembers stumbling across SCP soldiers
on his way to Site-19 that exhibited the same
“no pain” mentality that this Samuel Ross
seems to have.
After that odd statement by Samuel Ross there
was the sound of wind.
It started slow at first, then ramped up until
it was howling like a hurricane.
That’s when the screaming started.
The screams became louder and climbed to a
higher pitch.
Then the room went dead silent.
The last thing that Samuel Ross said was,
“I really liked you guys, so I was trying
to be nice.
We're so kind to you, you know.
We fight in the light so you can die in the
dark.”
Pietro sits back on his haunches and rocks
back and forth.
He has an ominous feeling that there is a
connection between the missing pain of the
SCP soldiers, and the reason why the Foundation
declared war on humanity.
The soldier who told the story of Samual Ross
stands up.
“After that interview is when the destruction
of Ganzir started from the inside.
It is why the Global Occult Coalition is no
more.
God help us all.”
The soldier, finished with his story, turns
from the others and starts to walk away.
As the soldier makes his way towards the woods
Pietro can just barely make out that he’s
taken his pistol from its holster before he
disappears into the darkness.
The world truly has gone mad.
Pietro opens the briefcase and blacks out.
Pietro sluggishly continues his walk.
He’s moving down a rocky path in the middle
of the forest and his will to keep going is
slowly being drained.
The only reason he has not sat down and given
up is because of the driving urge to get the
briefcase to 579.
He wants so badly to concentrate and discover
the reason that the Foundation released the
SCPs on humanity, but the need to reach 579
won’t let him to focus on anything else.
He’s noticed though that every time he opens
the briefcase to skip ahead, he makes less
and less progress.
The warm feeling of the first few transports
has been replaced by a nauseated headache
every time he comes out of the trance.
Pietro exits the forest into an open field.
The wind blows across the high grass looking
like green waves, and standing scattered throughout
the field are statues.
As Pietro approaches, he sees that they are
statues of Mobile Task Force Foundation soldiers.
He slowly walks closer to the white marble
statues.
He reaches the first one and looks at the
face of the frozen soldier, his eyes have
been scooped out, all that remains are black,
empty, sockets.
The arms of the soldier have been carved into
blades, like a praying mantis.
He walks past the first statue and proceeds
to the next one when he hears something move
in the grass behind him.
He spins around to look at the statue.
He could have swore it was in a slightly different
position.
No, that’s crazy, Pietro thinks.
He continues to the next statue.
It is another carving of a MTF soldier, no
eyes, blades for arms.
“This is really creepy,” Pietro says aloud.
He proceeds through the field.
He walks up a slight hill and turns around
to look at the field of statues.
What he sees is terrifying.
The statues have all moved and are now in
different positions.
It appears as if they were slashing through
the area looking for something… or someone.
Pietro continues over the hill and comes upon
a group of refugees.
They are picking through the field looking
for food to eat.
A fog begins to move in, it is being swept
across the meadow by the wind.
Pietro watches from a distance as the fog
envelopes the small group.
Suddenly there is screaming and the sound
of blades going through flesh.
The screams cease almost immediately.
Pietro runs down the hill to where the refugees
were.
The fog lifts.
The group of people have been cut to pieces.
Standing in the middle of the carnage is one
of the MTF soldier statues, blood dripping
from its blade arms.
Pietro knows what to do… he runs.
After a few miles Pietro slows to catch his
breath.
“Those statues must have been created by
the Foundation” he thinks, “It’s as
if they are frozen in place, but as soon as
you take your eyes off them they can move
with killer speed.
Even in the suit my eyesight can stop them…
but they can’t see me… they must know
I’m there though since they can’t move.”
Pietro Wilson opens the briefcase one again,
for what he didn’t know would be the last
time.
When he comes to this time he is near Site-62c.
He can feel himself being pulled stronger
than ever in the direction of his destination.
He walks down a deserted road past the husks
of burnt vehicles and at the end is the gate
to Site-62c.
There are no guards or security of any kind.
It looks like the site has been abandoned
for a long time and the gate is wide open,
beckoning Pietro Wilson into Site-62c... where
SCP-579 waits.
Pietro Wilson enters the dark hallway he somehow
knows leads down into the crypt of Site-62c.
The walls drip with what he hopes is water
from leaking pipes, but it has a metallic
smell, and is much too red to actually be
water.
He begins to feel nauseous.
It gets harder to breathe.
Even the SCP-5000 suit can’t keep him calm.
He turns and runs back up the stairs out of
Site-62c.
He stops a few feet from the entryway, bends
over, and vomits.
Pietro begins to sob uncontrollably as the
memories of everything that has happened over
the past several months suffocates his will
to go on.
Then, as if an invisible force that refuses
to let him go takes control.
Pietro feels as if a gun has been shoved into
the small of his back.
He is being sent back into Site-62c whether
he wants to go or not.
He is unsure if what is forcing him back into
the base is inside the briefcase, his own
uncontrollable urge to know what is going
on, or SCP-579 itself, but he cannot stop
himself from re-entering the doorway and preceding
into Site-62c.
He doesn’t know what SCP-579 looks like,
but Pietro has a sinister feeling that it
is watching him.
He reaches the bottom of the stairway and
proceeds down a dark hallway.
The power went out long ago and the only light
in the depths of Site-62c is the dim glow
coming from the helmet of the SCP-5000 suit.
Pietro notices long gashes along the concrete
walls, as if someone took a giant knife and
dragged it from one end of the hallway to
the other.
There is something at the end of the corridor
that Pietro can’t make out.
As he gets closer the lights on the SCP-5000
suit begin to flicker.
The thing at the end of the hallway seems
to move slightly each time the lights on the
suit dim.
The lights of the suit go out completely and
the entire hallway is plunged into darkness.
Only for a second though, and when the lights
come back on a statue of a MTF soldier looms
over Pietro, its eyes are empty sockets, its
lips are turned up in a snarl, the arms have
been filed into blades.
“No!”
Pietro screams.
He dodges around the statue, the moment it
is out of his sight he hears the sound of
blades on concrete, as the statue of the soldier
comes to life and begins slashing its way
down the hallway.
It cannot see Pietro, but it knows he is there.
It slashes all around, trying to connect with
whoever is there with it.
Pietro runs to the end of the hallway and
reaches a door.
He presses against the heavy metal door open,
straining against its weight all while the
blind statue is still slashing, coming closer
and closer.
The door is almost open, but then Pietro feels
a blade lacerate the back of the suit, cutting
deeply into the skin of his back, missing
his spinal cord by millimeters.
Another blade enters through the back of his
shoulder piercing straight through.
He somehow pulls himself through the cracked
doorway and kicks the metal door shut behind
him.
He can hear the banging and scraping of blades
outside of the metal door.
The creature has not given up and is trying
to break in.
Pietro turns around to see he is in an observation
chamber full of instruments and screens.
Blood runs down his back from the wounds inflicted
by the statue.
He walks slowly over to the window, on the
desk in front of him is a file labeled SCP-579.
He looks through the observation glass and
down into the chamber below.
It is too dark to make anything out, but Pietro
can feel that SCP-579 is down there looking
up at him.
Pietro looks to his left and sees a hole in
the floor.
He walks over and looks down.
It leads right into the containment chamber
of 579.
“Let’s get this over with,” Pietro says
out loud.
He holds the briefcase over the hole and tries
to open his hand.
His finger won’t budge.
SCP-579 wants him to hand deliver the briefcase..
Pietro Wilson takes a deep breath, closes
his eyes, and steps into the opening of the
hole.
He falls.
In the moments before he lands in SCP-579’s
containment chamber something comes to him.
He realizes that he isn’t going to be a
hero, he isn’t going to figure out why the
SCP Foundation is trying to wipe out humanity…
and he isn’t going to survive.
He lands hard on the ground below.
It is completely dark, except for a shadow
that moves in the corner of the containment
chamber.
Pietro Wilson creates one last log, “if
anyone ever reads this, please, please, figure
out why.
Explain it to me.
Someone … anyone.
I don't get it.
I just don't get it…”
SCP-579 steps into the glow that the SCP-5000
suit is giving off.
Pietro Wilson looks up at it.
“Oh … so that's how it is.”
he says before SCP-5000 creates its final
log: LIFE SIGNS LOST.
SCP-5000 appeared in a flash of light in the
containment chamber of SCP-579 located in
Site-62C.
The researchers monitoring SCP-579 had no
idea where the suit came from or why it contained
the body of Pietro Wilson, a foundation employee
who is assigned to Site-06 and is very much
alive.
Wilson appears to have no knowledge of SCP-5000
or memories of the events logged in SCP-5000’s
databanks.
Although the suit is believed to have been
capable at one point of a number of anomalous
functions and abilities, the damage it has
sustained has rendered it inoperable except
for the storage of data files, which have
now been archived and stored on secure Foundation
servers.
But is that really the case?
The fact is, the tale of Pietro Wilson and
SCP - 5000 is one of the most complex and
mysterious events in the SCP universe.
You’ve got questions, and we’ve got answers
- Why Pietro?
What was in the briefcase?
What exactly happened at the end of the story?
And perhaps most importantly of all, why did
the SCP Foundation abandon their mission,
and make destroying all of humanity their
new primary directive?
Whenever you’re dealing with splintered
realities and mind-melting nightmares, there’s
bound to be a number of interpretations.
And we’re eager to explain one of the more
popular ones right here.
Soon, you’ll know it all - but to find out,
we need to start at the beginning.
Our hero, Foundation employee Pietro Wilson,
was going about his day at Exclusionary Site-06.
However, normal operations were interrupted
when a Mobile Task Force turned Foundation
Hit Squad stormed in and began executing employees
left and right as part of their wider plan
to wipe out humanity.
Pietro got lucky though, and managed to find
SCP - 5000, making him undetectable to the
invading MTF squad.
This brings us to our first questions: Why
Pietro?
And how does killing Foundation staff help
advance the O5 council’s goal of overthrowing
humanity?
The answer to both questions has everything
to do with the site that Pietro and his coworkers
were at when the attack went down - Exclusionary
Site-06.
Exclusionary Sites are a very special kind
of Foundation site that utilizes the same
technology as the Scranton Box - a container
used to protect important items from reality
warpers - but on a far more ambitious scale.
Because of the use of this technology, these
Exclusionary Sites are essentially resistant
to CK-Class Restructuring Scenarios and Temporal
Anomalies, those are where reality and or
history itself are changed by a powerful entity.
This makes them a perfect location for, say,
staff wanting to stage a revolt when their
leaders have decided to wipe out humanity.
The Foundation wished to eliminate the personnel
stationed at these protected sites as a precautionary
measure, before moving onto the main phase
of their plan.
But this attack was just one part of the Foundation’s
wider scheme to purge their ranks of dissenters
before putting their final mission into place.
In order to make sure there were no internal
threats left who could pose a threat to the
new main directive, the Foundation murdered
all the staff at Exclusionary Sites, hunted
down and assassinated any resigned employees,
and killed off any humanoid or human-sympathetic
SCPs, leaving no one who could stop them.
Or at least they thought there was no one
left…
While all of this was happening, Pietro suited
up and exited the site.
So, why Pietro?
Because he got lucky, and he happened to stumble
upon SCP - 5000.
He wasn’t the Chosen One, nor was he in
any way exceptional, beyond his willingness
to see his quest for answers through to the
bitter end.
Pietro really could have been any of us if
we were in his situation.
When Pietro escaped, he found the world in
disarray.
SCPs had been released on a global scale - destroying
infrastructure, massacring civilians, and
assassinating key political figures.
The Foundation had even gone public, for the
first time ever, with their new intentions:
Destroy all humans.
Pietro decided to head to Site-19 and get
to the bottom of their madness.
On his way there, he saw a group of Mobile
Task Force members, performing a bizarre stabbing
ritual to see who among them could feel pain.
Remember this, it’ll be important later.
Like a lot of small moments in the story of
SCP - 5000, these are puzzle pieces that can
be fit together to create the true picture
of what’s happening out of the chaos.
At Site-19, among the dead-eyed Foundation
workers plotting mass killings, Pietro found
a treasure trove of vital information.
There he learned about the existence of Project
PNEUMA, an O5 Council-approved initiative
to map out the human psychosphere - otherwise
known as the collective unconscious.
He also found a redacted unanimous vote from
the O5 Council and Ethics Committee, as well
as a redacted series of directives sent out
to Senior Staff and Site Directors, which
caused a wave of suicides and resignations.
During his search, Pietro also discovered
a second series of directives sent out to
the remaining Site Directors and Senior Staff,
including the phrase “Harden your heart.”
These directives are known to some as “The
Cure.”
While Pietro didn’t have the context to
put all this together yet, these are more
vital clues to what happened.
The PNEUMA Project is what incited the Foundation’s
motivation to destroy humanity - killing off
humans is actually secondary to eliminating
something hiding else that’s hiding within
the human psychosphere - again that’s the
collective unconsciousness of all humans.
The O5 Council and the Ethics Committee were
unanimous in their approval of this project,
which was like deciding to burn down a house
to kill the inhabitant inside, except in this
scenario, humanity is the house.
So who or what exactly is the inhabitant?
You’ll find that out soon.
The next thing Pietro knew, he was sitting
half way across the country, with no memory
of the previous three months.
He was also carrying a briefcase with no knowledge
of what was inside except that it was“not
round.”
He also had a strange compulsion to deliver
the briefcase to SCP - 579, for reasons he
didn’t fully understand, but he hoped that
doing so would lead him to some answers.
Pietro may not have known what he was holding,
but we do.
The clue here is “not round” - which is
the only confirmed fact about SCP - 055, otherwise
known as The Anti-Meme.
This is an SCP with the primary anomalous
property of literally being unknowable.
People who observe it forget what they observed,
and have no memory of even looking at 055
in the first place.
This is why the briefcase was able to act
as Pietro’s personal “Skip” button.
Pietro was physically covering the distance
he traveled, but every time he opened the
briefcase and looked at SCP-055, he forgot
that period of time, making it seem as though
he simply skipped forwards.
The thing he was skipping towards, SCP - 579,
is an equally mysterious and highly dangerous
SCP contained within Site-62C.
Nobody even really knows what 579 is, only
that it’s an anomaly so dangerous that the
entirety of Site-62C was built to contain
it.
So what’s so important about bringing these
two together?
That, and the vital importance of Pietro’s
final mission, will become clear very soon.
Pietro continued his journey with the briefcase,
encountering more horrors and countless deaths
upon the way.
He finally found some solace in coming across
a group of Global Occult Coalition soldiers
discussing the interrogation of a captured
member of Foundation staff named Samuel Ross.
Two quotes from Ross’ enigmatic speech are
of particular interest here.
The first, in response to the threat of torture,
was “Do what you want.
Once you realize you're not supposed to feel
pain, there's nothing to be afraid of anymore.”
The second, after witnessing the death of
his captors, was “Look what you've done
to yourselves.
I told you you wouldn't like it, didn't you?
That's why you hear your voice.
But you wanted to know so badly.
I really liked you guys, so I was trying to
be nice.
We're so kind to you, you know.
We fight in the light so you can die in the
dark...disgusting.”
Do these quotes sound a little familiar?
The first because, as Pietro himself recalled,
the MTF members getting stabbed earlier also
didn’t seem to feel pain.
The second, because describing people as “disgusting”
is an adjective favoured by another infamous
SCP...
SCP-682.
This brings us back to “The Cure” - the
document disseminated by the O5 Council, instructing
people to “Harden Their Hearts.”
Whatever the Foundation discovered in the
human psychosphere, it’s apparently the
cause of all pain, and hence, when the Foundation
discovered it, they were able to train themselves
out of pain.
And as for the SCP - 682 reference - This
is a being that despises life, and it’s
believed by some that the reason 682 holds
this belief is that it’s always known about
whatever the Foundation recently discovered
through Project PNEUMA.
Decrypted text logs in the Foundation files
confirm this in a documented exchange between
O5-1 and Tejani, the head of the Foundation
Ethics Committee.
In their conversation they confirm the existence
of The Cure - which deprived the personnel
of everything from pain to empathy - being
disseminated among staff prior to the massacre,
and of the Foundation’s sudden ideological
alignment with SCP - 682.
And they had found something else too, referred
to simply as IT . Whatever IT was, it was
the reason Foundation Command decided to wipe
out humanity.
But what is IT?
What could possibly be so bad it was worth
killing all of humanity?
Perhaps most surprising of all is that Pietro
ran into the creature’s physical manifestation,
and he barely even considered it - due to
being occupied by avoiding the attacks of
the statue like, mantis-armed “Blinkers.”
Pietro made an entry in his log though, describing
the strange entity and described it like “a
person stretched out… like the space around
them was stretched out, and they were being
stretched along with it…
Their body went from the ground up to the
clouds, and their jaw swung at right angles.
There were these gaps, as well, black gaps
in space around its body, like wings.”
Foundation staff were fighting it, shooting
at this strange entity but their weapons had
no effect.
This creature, this IT, is a being that inhabits
the human psychosphere - meaning it exists
within the minds of all humans on some level,
driving and manipulating them to mysterious
ends.
What can it do?
What does it want?
It seems that the only people who know are
the O5 Council and the Foundation Ethics Committee
who were privy to the PNEUMA report.
But whatever it was they saw, they believed
it was worth killing off all of humanity just
to stop it.
As indicated by the unanimous vote from the
Ethics Committee, omnicide was a more ethical
choice compared to the alternative.
The influence of IT was also likely what gave
Pietro the strong, subconscious desire to
unite the briefcase containing SCP - 055 with
SCP - 579 - even at the cost of his own life.
This brings us to our final questions:
Why was it so important to unite SCP - 055
and SCP- 579, and what did this act serve
to achieve?
As Pietro, wounded by the Blinkers and lingering
on the edge of death, finally delivered the
briefcase into 579’s containment chamber,
he acknowledged the fact that he was no hero.
But that’s where Pietro was wrong.
After the destruction of SCP - 2000, Pietro
was in control of one of the only remaining
ways to save the world.
The combination of the anomalous effects of
055 and 579, as laid out in Roget’s Proposal
and the article for SCP - 2998, is the Foundation’s
ultimate trump card for preventing an XK-Class
end of the world scenario.
If the two are united during said scenario,
the universe resets to a time before the XK
Class scenario began, and prevents it from
happening.
In this case, Pietro uniting the two created
a new reality where the PNEUMA Project was
never launched, and IT was never discovered
- thereby averting the apocalypse.
The corpse of poor dead Pietro and the highly
damaged SCP - 5000 suit he wore were the only
evidence that this alternate reality ever
existed.
This means that the collaboration between
Pietro Wilson and the suit he just happened
to stumble upon quite literally saved the
universe as we know it from a Foundation that
had gone rogue.
In this regard, he’s one of the greatest
heroes the universe has ever known, even if
his actions weren’t entirely his own.
After all, he got a helping hand from the
suit, and another from IT - who still lurks
in all our minds, mercifully undiscovered,
to this day.
What was IT’s grand plan or purpose that
triggered all the madness?
Anyone who ever knew for sure resides in a
universe that no longer exists, and we can
only hope that a history that never happened
is somehow unable to repeat itself in ours.